this morning there are new signs the
Taliban is cracking down on opposition
in Afghanistan Taliban militants fire
weapons into the air to break up a
demonstration in the capital the people
were protesting the taliban's reported
capture of the country's last
uncontrolled Province Charlie dagadas
and Doha Qatar were top officials are
holding talks on Afghanistan Charlie
good morning
good morning to you Nate these aren't
just anti-taliban protests a lot of
people are shouting long live the
resistance in support of resistance
fighters in pancher now if this
continues it could pose a major problem
for the Taliban
they raged in Kabul again today
anti-taliban protests that are growing
in size and fury by the day
heavy gunfire broke out shots fired to
disperse the crowds sending people
scrambled
the protesters include many Women
shouting Freedom other demonstrators
yelling death to Pakistan for meddling
in Afghanistan
another demonstration held in the north
of the country in support of women's
rights each protest a bold gamble
against a regime known for its extreme
brutality
as the Taliban tightens its grip on
power the U.S state Department says an
American family of four was able to flee
over land but there's growing outrage
over Americans and Afghans still
stranded in the country satellite images
show six evacuation planes at the mazara
Sharif airport amid accusations they've
been grounded by the Taliban for nearly
a week Marina Legree is the founder of
Ascend Athletics a group helping Afghan
women and girls trying to get out the US
government has contacts with the Taliban
I mean these are the same people we've
been negotiating with for a very long
time in Doha surely there's some
Outreach that could be done and some
levers that could be pulled to release
these people
Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
arrived here in Doha for some high-level
crisis talks he said they're in touch
with around 100 Citizens U.S citizens
who are still in Afghanistan and they're
doing everything they can to make sure
those charter flights are able to leave
safely Tony
dagada for us once again in Doha cutter
Charlie thank you very much